in this video I want to introduce DNA
replication as the first part of the
central dogma and I want to talk a
little bit about it just a sort of
overview so DNA replication this is the
process by which we make DNA so DNA
replication is done by DNA polymerase so
DNA polymerase or DNA pause it's
abbreviated does this it adds dntps
right deoxynucleotide triphosphates to
an existing chain how does it know how
does DNA polymerase know which base to
add well it's gonna do that it's gonna
add the bases depending on the existing
looks like an ad it's gonna add bases
that are complementary to the template
DNA so there's already a DNA strand
there that it's that the DNA polymerase
is acting on so if there is a T on the
existing DNA strand and then polymerase
knows to add an A and if there's a G in
no statice so on and so forth
so where does this actually begin where
does the innate application begin it
begins at what's called an origin of
replication
now prokaryotes have one origin of
replication whereas eukaryotes have many
origins of replication and this is due
to the fact that prokaryotes have a
circular DNA circular genome whereas
eukaryotes have linear DNA so that looks
kind of like this so this is one origin
of replication that's kind of messy but
that this is a eukaryote here as many so
this is a prokaryote and this is in a
eukaryote many so DNA replication is
bi-directional right and this is this is
because of the strands being anti
parallel recall that one strand will be
running 503 prime the other strand
running five primary behind the other
way so the two strands one will be
synthesized one way and the other will
be synthesized the other way now how I
know which way was going in which way
the others going the synthesis direction
is 5 prime to 3 Prime and how often does
this happen the simple answer is always
this always happens synthesis always
occurs 5 prime to 3 prime so if this is
the strand is going 5 from the 3 prime
that I would be adding the anti parallel
strands the other way right 5 prime to 3
prime and then for this one I'd be
adding a 5 prime to 3 Prime this way
I'll talk more about that in a later
video how does what is the reaction the
actual reaction that DNA polymerase
catalyzes the reaction that catalyzes it
is the action in which we have the 3
prime Oh H group of an existing strand
it acts as a nucleophile attacking the
five prime phosphate group of the next
dntp causing a pyrophosphate and a guy
prime phosphate to hop off so the
details of this are in the how to draw a
nucleic acids video which I've done
previously so go ahead and watch that
video and check that out for the details
behind this reaction so when this
pyrophosphate hops off this is the
equivalent to 2 ATP's being used because
this part of phosphate can be hydrolyzed
off into 2 inorganic phosphates so
essentially it's kind of like taking an
ATP to an a MP and and usually two
high-energy phosphate bonds so here when
this happens when this nucleophilic
attack occurs and the pyrophosphate
leaves there's a covalent bond that is
formed that covalent bond is called a
phosphodiester bond and specifically
since the 3-prime always attacked the 5
attack the five prime phosphate it's a 3
prime 5 prime
phospho diester bond and again the
details behind that are in this video
okay so one thing that is important to
know about DNA polymerase is that it
cannot begin it cannot begin de novo now
what de novo means is of nothing what is
that what does that mean right what does
it mean that DNA polymerase cannot begin
to novo DNA polymerase requires an
existing 3-prime o age group to act on
right this three pi Malaysia that's
acting as a nucleophile needs to be
present so how does that happen
right that's this is a problem because
if that's the case then how can DNA
polymerase begin if there's no initial I
mean if it needs a three from O age
group and there isn't already DNA then
how can DNA be synthesized at all
the answer to that question lies with
this enzyme here prime ace prime ace is
an RNA polymerase a special RNA
polymerase and it lays down this thing
called a primer it's an RNA primer which
is basically just a small strand of RNA
and what that RNA primer does is it
provides the 3 prime of age this primer
here provides the 3 prime o h4 DNA
polymerase to act on so why is it that
primary so an RNA polymerase can lay
down a primer the reason why is because
the RNA polymerase can synthesize de
novo ok so it's it's a little bit more
powerful in that sense that it can
synthesize the Nobel while DNA
polymerase cannot so I hope that DNA
replication overview was helpful and
maybe taught you something that you
didn't already know one last thing I am
a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact maybe
move University at gmail.com and if you
want more details check out the
description below thank you for watching